i hate intros one punch man season two e
episode one
we kick things off with saitama and
jenno's heading home from the store
they come across the rank seven s-class
hero king who is confronted by a robot
called
g4 wanting to fight him to assess his
strength
g4 is a good sport so he lets king go to
the bathroom first and we learn that
king
actually doesn't have any powers he just
so happy to be around monsters right
before they were slain
people thought he was the one
responsible and this happened enough
times to where he
made s-class knowing that he can't fight
the monster he decides to flee from the
fight and jenno's has to step in to
fight g4
instead
king is an otaku so he returns to his
house to play some video games once
saitama shows up because he had followed
him he had followed him to find out why
he was running from the fight but the
two end up playing games until a huge
bird monster attacks his apartment he is
then forced to confess to saitama that
he doesn't have any powers and he
recognizes that whenever he ran into a
monster
saitama was actually the one who killed
it to his surprise saitama isn't even
mad and he says that he wants to hang
out again sometime back to janos who
managed to defeat g4
and brought back some of the parts in
order to use them to upgrade his body
we then hop on over to the president of
the hero association who is trying to
hire villains to help with the
increasing amount of monster attacks
that have been happening
speedo sound sonic is there but he's
just looking for saitama so he can get a
rematch once he realizes he's not there
though he decides to leave
episode 2. we get a new face in garo
who interrupts the meeting and claims
that he is a monster declaring
every human as his enemy he attacks and
defeats all of the villains there
as well as three a-class heroes that
were there as security
later on we hop on over to saitama who's
hanging out when jenna senses someone
coming
side tom is pretty distracted with his
game so janice goes to check it out
alone
and he finds speedo sound sonic outside
looking for saitama to get his rematch
20 minutes later there's a knock at the
door and when saitama answers it we meet
the rank one class b
hero fubaki or hellish blizzard she is
there to convince saitama to join her
faction and rank b
because he won't be able to climb
through the ranks without her help
that's a kick [ __ ] w so he declines
her prompting her and her posse to try
and attack him
obviously this doesn't go quite as
planned and he makes quick work of him
he then sees jenno's fighting with sonic
who is keeping up with his speed
relatively well thanks to his new
upgrades
jenos prepares to unleash a huge blast
so saitama steps in and takes him out of
the fight because he was about to level
the neighborhood
sonic finally gets his chance to fight
saitama but immediately loses without
landing a single blow fubaki is shocked
by sai thomas power like everybody else
and later on while talking we learn that
she's actually the younger sister of
tatsumaki the rank 2
s-class hero she explains that she can't
be as strong as her older sister so she
made her faction to compensate for
that when asked why she doesn't shoot
for rank 1 in class a she explains that
a my mask is too strong and even
disciples of atomic samurai can't beat
him to get into s-class
jump on over to the hero association for
a quick scene where we see that they
give the hero names demon
cyborg to janos and caped baldi to
saitama
they don't seem too concerned about
garo's recent attack because they've
tasked
s-class heroes with handling him
meanwhile we see garo looking for strong
heroes to fight and he defeats tank top
vegetarian in the last scene
episode 3. we're going to look at
silverfang beating one of his pupils
named toronco down and expelling him
from his dojo trunk
goes to talk about it with saitama and
jenno's where he finds the other heroes
there as well they speculate that he
might have kicked him out because of the
reappearance of garrow who is
silverfang's former student
silverfing is trying to protect chironco
from getting caught up in the fight
because garo is very dangerous
later on sharonko is walking home at
night and comes across garo who attacked
the class c
rank 1 hero newman ryder soon after the
tank top squad shows up looking for garo
since he attacked the tank top
vegetarian
goro finds his first challenge against
an s-class hero while fighting tank top
master
tank top master thinks he has the upper
hand because garl wasn't going all out
but once he does he makes quick work of
him
and his squad drunk goes watching from
the sidelines but then decides it's time
to sack up and so he goes to fight garl
getting one tapped immediately
knowing how dangerous garrow is silver
fang calls in his brother bomb to help
in the fight
and they're the ones who come across the
beaten down boys saitama goes to visit
all the heroes in the hospital where he
learns more about garo's martial arts
back on over to garo who meets a boy
named tario reading a hero almanac that
describes all of the heroes and their
moves the almanac gives garl enough
information for him to plot his next
attack
he goes after the class a hero
goldenball and during their
fight he is joined by spring mustachio
to help him out
even though the duo managed to deal some
damage to garo they are both ultimately
defeated
back over to saitama who is curious
about martial arts so chiraco gives him
a ticket to a martial arts tournament
that he can go
watch djironko was supposed to compete
in the tournament so saitama gets the
idea to go in his place but it would be
against the rules so he goes to buy a
wig for a disguise
we'll allow shopping for a wig he comes
across garo who attacks him so saitama
gives him a good smack and knocks him
unconscious in the last scene
episode 4 we get a short flashback to
when garl was young he would always root
for the monsters to win in tv shows but
they were always beaten by the heroes
he felt bad that the monsters were
trying their best also but could never
seem to win so he decides that he'll
become the strongest monster
and will never lose regaining
consciousness garo can't remember
saitama or what happened to him
taro is reading his book again so garl
uses it to target metal bat and
watchdog man next we then see saitama
who signs up for the tournament under
charanka's name he then meets another
one of bang's former students named
sourface
sourface explains that last tournament's
winner was wolfman but then they found
wolfman later on
tied up so the real winner was actually
garo in disguise
this is why contestants are now
prohibited from using aliases or
disguises
we also learned that it was six months
ago when garo decided that he had
nothing more to learn and attacked all
of the students at bank's dojo
bang fought and defeated him while also
banishing him from the dojo which is
also when sauerface quit
the hero association wants to protect
its officials from the increasing amount
of monster attacks
middlebet is assigned to look after one
of the top sponsors of the hero
association narinki
he's also supposed to protect nariki's
son wakanma
but then they are attacked soon after by
junior centipede and
venus man trap after making quick work
of them they are attacked again but this
time by senior centipede and raffle
satan who tries to knock him out with
sleeping gas
he manages to counteract the gas and
kills both of them as well
cueing the entrance of the final boss a
dragon level monster named elder
centipede targets non-rinkies so him and
his son
are taken by some lower level heroes to
safety while metal bat holds him off
while fighting elder centipede he is
then targeted by garo forcing him to
focus on that fight instead
episode 5. middle knight is the next
hero on the scene to fight elder
centipede but he can't seem to do any
damage to it
back on over to garrow who had seemingly
defeated metal bat but points out that
if he managed to land
one shot on him then he would have been
in trouble middlebat actually wasn't out
of the fight just yet and launches
another attack catching garl off guard
and nearly kills him but he is stopped
by his little sister zenko
senko requests that they both stop
fighting and garo agrees because he kind
of has a soft spot for kids so he goes
to look for watchdog man
instead two monsters named phoenix man
and sludge
jellyfish approach garo to get him to
join the monsters association but he
refuses
all the monsters make their retreat with
metal knight tagging along on elder
centipede
ben gets into his first scrap with a
demon level monster called boxing demon
which he kills pretty quickly with a
barrage of punches
there are numerous other monsters who
start attacking the city as
well du s who is my personal favorite
monster uses her whips to mind control
people
and is attacking heroes when fubuki
steps in to stop her
back on over to the tournament where we
meet too many side characters for me to
care about listing but we also meet
bakuzan and sui ryu who are both
supposed to be extremely strong
in his first match saitama goes against
zackos who was talking some crazy [ __ ]
to him earlier and in the last scene
after the credits we see him lose in one
hit
episode 6. we see the hero lightning max
faced up against sweet rio who quickly
defeats him
meanwhile jenos who is at the tournament
watching gets a message saying that
there are a lot of monster attacks
happening around the city so he goes to
fight the ones nearby
so her face manages to beat his opponent
jakku man
in their first fight so itama's second
match is against bakuzan who had won the
tournament two times before that but
still gets knocked out in one punch
over to janos who goes around slaying
multiple monsters until he meets a demon
level monster
awakened cockroach he uses adhesives to
keep him in place but cockroach boy
sacrifices his legs in order to make his
retreat while genus's back is turned he
is attacked by a mysterious monster
we also learned that waganma was
captured but his dad wasn't there's a
lot of fights going on as we hop back
on over to do as who had taken control
of all of fubaki's men
she attacks fubiki also but her will
prevents her from succumbing to the mind
control and she also says that when she
takes damage her sister knows about it
this cues the entrance of her big sister
tatsumaki so do s wants no part of that
fight and uses her henchmen to buy her
time to
escape after the credits garo sees
watchdog man saitama is in the bathroom
and a dragon level monster named koketsu
is revealed to be the one who approached
and defeated genos
there's also a my masks concert that is
attacked by
monsters a group of monsters are
attacking a hospital where a muman rider
and tank top master at
a monster named nyan is looking for a
puddy pudding prisoner but the prisoners
reveal that puddy putty prisoner escaped
the prison to fight against the monsters
and finally two monsters named eurogiro
and orochi have captured metal knight
episode 7 with so many monsters showing
up the s-class heroes finally respond to
fight with them
child emperor the rank 5 s-class hero
uses his
robot to fight against eyesight she
finds where he's controlling the robot
from but then she's eaten by the rank 10
s-class hero pig god we see garo who's
about to go in on watchdog the s-class
rank 12 hero but then he's suddenly
attacked by another monster
drive knight the rank 9 s-class hero
wins his fight and then tries to
interrogate the monster to get
information
death gatling the a-class rank a hero
goes to fight hundred eyes octopus but
is told to stand down by flash
flash rank 13 s-class hero he fights
with the monster and then tatsumaki
steps in to chaos him and takes out the
monster
a my mask mewman rider and tank top
master all managed to defeat the
monsters that had targeted them
now hop on over to atomic samurai who
meets with his council of swordsmen
one of the swordsmen named rogery
brought monster cells to them in hopes
that they'll join the monster
association he explains that if they eat
the monster cells they'll turn into a
powerful monster with even more power
than they have now
when declined he turns into a monster
and atomic samurai is forced to kill him
before setting out to find the monsters
association
at the tournament saitama faces against
sauerface and jose quickly beating both
of them as well
this progresses him to the finals where
he faces against swee ryu
long story short they both want a
challenging fight and when saitama gets
his wig knocked off he's disqualified
from the tournament
this doesn't stop sweru and he continues
to attack him even though his attacks
don't really do any damage
one side tama feels like he understands
a little bit more about martial arts he
gives him a solid hip bump throwing him
into a wall
and ending the fight in the last scene
we see that the monster who defeated
genos is headed towards the tournament
episode 8. suey ryu is awarded for
winning the tournament since saitama
was disqualified the monster goketsu
shows up and we learned that he used to
be a human martial artist like the
contestants
he was defeated by the monsters and
eventually ended up joining them in
order to become more powerful
presenting the contestants with monster
cells he gives them the ultimatum of
joining the monster association or dying
jose and a handful of other fighters eat
the cells in order to become stronger
swee ryu is the only one who stands up
to them and manages to defeat the new
monsters including jose
he goes to fight goketsu next but soon
realizes that he's way too strong for
him getting beaten pretty bad
bakuzan is off to the side watching this
and sui ryu begs him for his help but he
refuses and ends up eating three of the
monster cells at once
the strain is too much on his body and
he ends up passing out
koketsu orders his crow minions to
finish the job when lightning max
and snek show up in their hero gear to
help fight back
they managed to defeat the crows but
when suiriu tries to run from goketsu he
gets cut off by bakuzan who had
successfully turned into a monster and
starts beating him up
goketsu gets a message from gilro who
tells him to fall back because s-class
heroes will be showing
up soon he warns bakuzan of this before
leaving him behind with swee rio because
bakuzan wants to continue toying with
him suey ryu admits defeat and pleads
with bakuzan to spare him but bakuzan
has no interest in that and wants to
kill him
in a last-ditch effort sweet rio cries
out hoping that a hero might hear him
this cues the entrance of saitama in the
last scene
episode 9. saitama is trying to figure
out where he knows bakuzan from since he
had just fought him as a human but then
he goes to attack saitama and he is
killed sui ryu asks who saitama really
is and he explains that he's actually a
hero that joined the tournament to learn
more about martial arts and because he
was bored
after learning that koketsu is the one
who defeated sweru and how strong he is
saitama goes looking for him soiru begs
him not to go fearing that he'll be
killed but after a few moments goketsu's
head lands in front of him after saitama
had killed him once we rio had seen his
strength he decides that he wants to
become a hero
and he also wants to become saitama's
disciple jump on over to pudupuri
prisoner who defeats the demon level
free hugger by hugging him to death he
then gets a call saying that the inmates
in his prison were taken hostage by the
monsters
well walking back saitama reflects on
the fact that he is still too strong and
ultimately just bored because he can't
find a worthy opponent
he runs into king who drops a lot of
useful wisdom on him that he had learned
from a manga but none of it really
sticks so the two of them go to play
games instead
garo had lost to watchdog man due to his
unorthodox fighting style and is amped
up that he still has so much to learn
when he sees king and saitama walking he
gets pumped up for another fight with an
s-class hero he rushes that king to
attack him but saitama kicks him through
a wall knocking him
unconscious again over to sonic who is
training when he is approached by ninjas
named
galewind and hellfire flame who turn out
to be monsters working with the
association
they give him monster cells in hopes
that he will join their side
he agrees but makes the mistake of
cooking the monster cells which ends up
preventing the transformation and gives
him diarrhea instead
s-class rank a zombie man is tracking
martial gorilla who runs into armor
gorilla from season 1.
marshall gorilla picks a fight with
armored gorilla who was just out getting
groceries so armored gorilla knocks him
out this makes zombie man want to follow
armored gorilla instead in the last
scene the hero association gets a
message from the monster association
episode 10. guroguro and destro
claridium take over the body of one of
the executives and negotiate with the
hero association
they declare war and challenge the hero
association to send their best heroes to
fight them in an all-out battle
using the captured wagonma as leverage
destro claridium then prepares to open
fire on the other executives but is
stopped by super alloy darkshine which
is the s-class
rank 11 hero before he can we then look
at a meeting in the monster association
where monster king orochi brings
everyone up to speed on what their plan
is
he then realizes that awakened
cockroaches there and eats him because
of him losing to jenno's who then think
about killing doo s
also but let's be realistic when you
know that your fan base is a bunch of
lonely nerds like me you're not going to
kill off that character
guru gyro finds goketsu's body after he
didn't show up for the meeting
this is a pretty good indicator that
they might have underestimated the
heroes
goro regains consciousness after saitama
had kicked him through the wall and
seized death gatling an a-class hero but
can't fight him because of his injuries
so he retreats to heal up in a shack
the shack just so happens to be where
tario and his friends hang out and they
make tario go to get rid of him while
they're talking
death gatling and seven other heroes
surround the place to capture garo
in his current condition he's having a
hard time keeping up with the barrage of
attacks even being hit by two poison
arrows in the fight
episode 11. garrow points out that there
are no s-class heroes so he's confused
as to why they think they can defeat him
death gatling goes on to explain that
the hero association only cares about
s-class heroes so he assembled a team of
lower-ranking members to prove that
they're useful too
garo then starts to turn the tables on
the heroes taking down half of them
while death gatling tries to get a shot
off on garo he gets close to glasses and
we get a flashback of him being in
fubiki's little clan
and was holding them back the inside
thomas saves him from a monster and
encourages him to keep trying which was
nice and all but garo still kicks the
[ __ ] out of him now it's just death
gatling left and with no human shields
he can use his finisher move on garo
goro asks him not to because tario is
still in the shed
and could be in the line of fire but
death gatling thinks this is a bluff
he uses death's shower firing all of his
bullets off at once
in order to protect tario garo goes on
to block all of the bullets and then
proceeds to defeat death gatling now
that he's out of bullets when taro comes
out he no longer sees garo as a friendly
man he sees him as a monster
and so he runs away in terror glasses
had managed to send out a signal for
help so without any time to rest
janus shows up to fight garu saitama and
king get the signal also and saitama
thinks back on all of the times that
jenos was injured in his fights so they
decide to go make sure everything is
okay
janos has the upper hand in the fight so
garo tries emulating watchdog man's
moves to fight back
eventually he is cornered but then
monsters from the monsters association
step in to save him and recruit him into
their ranks
bang and bomb show up to help in the
fight with bomb taking on the monsters
allowing bang to focus on the fight with
his former pupil
episode 12. garo is outclassed and
losing to bang and bomb so he starts
having more flashbacks of when he was a
kid
another reason he hates hiros so much is
because a popular kid in his class named
tat chan always used to gang up on him
with his friends and beat him up
this was part of the game they played
where he was the monster and they were
all the heroes ganging up on him to beat
him
then whenever they got in trouble for
fighting they would always blame it on
him he just sees heroes as people
peeking on the weak
in this case monsters as he gets ready
to make his last stand against the
heroes phoenix man swoops in and carries
him off while knocking the others back
genos launches an attack at them as
their fling but the elder centipede
returns to block the shot
bang and bomb launch a powerful attack
against elder centipede but even that
isn't enough only causing it to shed its
armor
genos decides to fight it in order to
buy time for the others to get the class
a heroes to safety but after throwing
everything he has at it he still can't
do damage
as it starts nearing the city king shows
up with a megaphone to antagonize elder
centipede
saying that the class s rank 1 hero
blast was there to fight it
blast was the hero that fought elder
centipede a while back
and injured it so badly that it had to
retreat underground
seeking vengeance against blast
centipede boy starts charging towards
king's voice once it closes in on king
saitama launches a surprise attack to
kill the centipede with one hit
in the last scene after the credits we
see that garo had fallen unconscious as
phoenix man takes him to meet with the
king of monsters orochi
well i'm gonna be doing the future
seasons and you can find that on the
left side whenever i'm finished with it
or you can check out all of the one
punch man recaps in the playlist on the
right side you can also find the links
in the description below and the only
thing i hate more than intros
is outros